Игорь А.: Да, в общем, я... Так, я
Александра: отключила VPN. Надеюсь, у меня теперь лучше.
Игорь А.: Вот, отлично, да. Да, смотрите, значит, начну тогда со своих вопросов, и потом перейдем уже непосредственно к тому продукту, который мы сейчас делаем. Немножко расскажите о себе с той
Игорь А.: точки зрения, с кем сейчас в основном работаете, там, родители, дети, кто чаще какого возраста приходит, может, подростки, да, кто ваш клиент.
Александра: Да, мой клиент в основном это люди, которые поступают, то есть абитуриенты, либо на бакалавриат, либо на магистратуру непосредственно. Вообще я готовлю либо высшую школу экономики,
Александра: уже с 2020 года, людей, которые делают проекты для поступления, на все направления в дизайн бакалавриата. То есть это прежде всего фэшн -дизайн и графический дизайн, также это дизайн
Александра: интерьера гейм дизайн но мои главные это фашин дизайн брендинг и все связано с драм дизайном вместе потому что это то где я училась
Игорь А.: работаю
Александра: я и стены кто поступает за границу и так получается что чаще всего это те кто поступают в италию потому что видимо я тоже училась в италии поэтому они тянутся к тому кто уже прошел
Александра: этот путь на также те кто поступает например, в Кисай или в Лидерлауде, то есть бывают люди, пытаются подкатить сразу несколько институтов, но тогда мы тоже готовимся и делаем портфолио
Александра: вместе с ними. Я чаще всего отвечаю за теоретическую часть, то есть подготовку тех людей, у которых нет, например, художественного образования, и которые астралияны, что не знают, и
Александра: хотят поступить в престижный босс, либо иногда я концентрируюсь только на портфолио в зависимости от задач, которые мне дает клиент либо родитель этого клиента. Потому что мы занимаемся
Александра: только практикой непосредственно. По -моему, точно так же получилось, кстати, с нашим клиентом, с Арком, с которым мы занимались, по -моему, 4 месяца, не около того, если я правильно
Александра: помню, в последок. он поступал марангоне и кажется еще пару каких -то вузов вот и я коммуницировала как раз с алиной с вашим представителем но обычно я коммуницирую непосредственно
Александра: с родителями или причем бывает иногда что я коммуницирую с родителями начиная не с нового такого
Александра: тогда мы уже с ними договариваться потому что кто -то
Александра: только только ищет себя и мы не
Александра: задача очень разные и наверное за сколько у кого -то вопрос вообще не финансовый вопрос
Александра: потому что заинтересовать прежде всего чтобы он
Александра: работа индивидуально вообще еще
Александра: подкреплять
Александра: я закончила питерский вуз бакалавриат но пока я училась в питерском вузе Я закончила в каком году. Я закончила.
Александра: По
Игорь А.: -моему, в 20 -м.
Александра: Я не знаю. Или в 16 -м я закончила. В общем, да. Мне 28 лет.
Александра: Я очень мало бываем собеседований, как вы понимаете.
Игорь А.: У нас тут не собеседование, у нас это
Александра: такие знакомства. какой -то формат такой, да. Нет, я закончила питерский вуз, с отличием, я проучилась один год из четырёх за границами славы, потому что можно было ещё там заведовать
Александра: в принципе, в Альфа, в Бетсана университет в Альфах. А потом я поступила на магистратуру уже в политехнический Миланск, вот это просто самый крупный итальянский вуз, И там я проучилась
Александра: два года на фэшн -брендинге и дизайне.
Игорь А.: Ну и, соответственно, я закончила два года назад. И
Александра: все это время я преподаю. Так что вот такой вот у меня путь.
Игорь А.: Классный путь. А вот если говорить сейчас про преподавание, насколько я понял, что все -таки большинство клиентов приходят через родителей, да? А вот если говорить там инста, может
Игорь А.: быть, какие -то площадки, Вот каким образом находят вас и ваши услуги? То есть это там может сарафанка, еще что -то?
Александра: Ну, сарафанное радио 100 % да, это лучшие клиенты по сарафанному радио, но обычно это еще Profi .ru, я в Profi .ru давно сидел на подвеске, мне кажется, с 20 -го года я уже там была.
Александра: И Instagram сейчас, ну у меня там где -то около 6 тысяч подписчиков, но это мне дает возможность собирать неплохие команды людей, группы на лекции, на вебинары. В принципе, это они.
Игорь А.: А если говорить, вот смотри, я так понял, прошу прощения, но ты уже, если говорить про линейку такую вот продуктов, то получается, есть поступление в УЗы в Италию, есть дизайн, и, возможно,
Игорь А.: есть какие -то еще бывают непрофильные обращения, и если бывают, то как ты их отрабатываешь? Может, кому -то передаешь их или там, не знаю, говоришь, не -не, я этим не занимаюсь?
Александра: Знаете, очень сильно зависит, на самом деле. Бывают, конечно, непрофильные обращения. Например, сейчас, сейчас я приехала в Россию, там видно, что у меня все сзади на русском. Я в России,
Александра: и сейчас меня попросили помочь девочке сделать проект, который, ну там девочки какой -то богатый папа и он выяснял пент -халл чтобы она сделала девочку лизу как у одного итальянского
Александра: фигурда но она не знает как это сделать технически и вот я сижу помогали там с проекторами со всеми судьбонок чтобы это как бы по плану как она придумала в голове вот девочка у меня
Александра: занимается поэтому как бы это мой студент в любом случае за него беру ответственность я согласилась им помочь хотя обычно вот именно руками я не помогаю но Но эти вещи, они такие, знаете,
Александра: небольшие, можно сказать, их можно обговаривать. И зависит от того, кто просит, потому что я сейчас просила в этой программе, что могла помочь. А так, да, не знаю, какие -то еще в этом
Александра: роде, но в принципе, да, бывают такие, бывает проекты,
Игорь А.: получается. хорошо я вот такой вопрос задам ну можно на него отвечать можно не отвечать как как чувствуете вот если говорить про клиентов которые сейчас есть какой для них чек на услуги
Игорь А.: нормальный то есть вот не ну можно вилку можно например вот там в час или как то вот как в целом формируете свою ценовую политику и какая она?
Александра: Ну, у меня в среднем где -то 5 -6 тысяч в час за 60 минут. То есть это не академический час. Ну, и предполагается, что занятие идет в полтора часа, то где -то 9 тысяч за полтора часа.
Александра: Где -то раз -два в неделю WhatsApp у меня обычно занимаются. Вот. Ну, и, конечно, у меня еще есть такой момент, что я люблю, когда мне платят в евро, потому что у меня ИП в Италии.
Александра: Поэтому если есть возможность платить в евро, то я могу как -то подумать насчет какой -то скидки, что -то, что -то будет. В общем, я всегда, когда мне была скидка с белой картой в Италии.
Александра: Понятно,
Игорь А.: это хорошо. На правильный счет.
Игорь А.: Значит, я тогда немножко расскажу суть нашей встречи. Спасибо, что поделились. И будет более понятно, зачем эти вводные вопросы были и как они как раз -таки касаются того продукта,
Игорь А.: который мы разрабатываем. Да, действительно, мы сейчас делаем продукт, который называется платформа Main Experts. На ней будут такие две большие основные роли. Это ученики и эксперты.
Игорь А.: Если говорить про учеников, все начинается с родителей, и родитель первый, мама либо папа подключает второго родителя, подключают детей, и все это формируется в такой общий семейный
Игорь А.: профиль. То есть родители могут переключаться между детьми, смотреть их успеваемость, какие -то там проведенные на платформе занятия и так далее. Но если говорить про то, чем конкретно,
Игорь А.: куда я сейчас буду рассказывать, куда я приглашаю пойти, мы делаем внутренний такой продукт, который хотим опробовать на своих экспертах, с которыми сейчас взаимодействуем. То есть
Игорь А.: наша методология, когда мы, например, с вами тоже взаимодействовали по тому же марку, она начинается с того, что к нам тоже часто приходят по поступлению в ВУЗы, в УК в основном мы
Игорь А.: отправляем, и в Италию, и в Сингапур, и Эмираты, но в основном большая часть студентов хочет в УК. Так вот, мы начинаем с того, что мы не подбираем вуз, а мы, условно говоря, на шаг
Игорь А.: назад отступаем и проводим профориентацию. И вот как раз таки, я зачем сейчас это рассказываю, такой маршрут простроить, что мы делаем в целом. То есть мы проводим эту профориентацию,
Игорь А.: в ней участвуют и родители, и участвуют дети, ребенок, которому мы проводим. То есть у родителей есть там свое тестирование, психологический и семейный контекст, и слой. У детей, кроме
Игорь А.: такого же теста, есть два больших теста. На основе один тест НАСА -вский, другой тест по личности, по склонности личности. И мы вот разбираем вот это все личность на атомы и потом сопоставляем
Игорь А.: с теми профессиями, которые могут подходить. Не знаю, знаете там эту методологию все или нет, но я сейчас расскажу, зачем я это все прям так рассказываю. И вот когда понятно из тестирования,
Игорь А.: что вот есть ребенок с такими -то предрасположенностями, и есть вот такие профессии, они ему подходят, мы там в процентах это все взвешиваем, условно говоря, вот это подходит там на
Игорь А.: 85%, вот это на 93%, вот это вообще 65%, и вы будете страдать, лучше туда не идти. Мы таким образом можем понять, в какой ВУЗ лучше поступить. И, соответственно, понимаем, что в ВУЗе
Игорь А.: есть программа. На первом году обучения вот эти программы в ВУЗе, на втором вот эти. Таким образом, мы такой большой маршрут выстраиваем от ребенок сейчас заканчивает среднюю школу,
Игорь А.: либо старшие классы, и до первой работы. И вот тоже там какие -то у нас есть в маршруте работы, которые он должен сделать, портфолио набрать. И вот мы как раз экспертов привлекаем,
Игорь А.: чтобы помочь это в портфолио собрать, либо какие -то навыки подтянуть. Где -то у кого -то язык, у кого -то математика и так далее. Вот. И как раз -таки, когда у нас был вот этот первый
Игорь А.: этап профориентации, делался вручную, мы могли там, пропускная способность агентства была буквально там один -два студента в месяц. Это такая большая, ну, действительно там отчет, там
Игорь А.: только один отчет формируется на более чем 40 страниц, который прям подробно вот разбирает эту личность, и потом уже поступление в ВУЗа строится на тех данных, которые дал наш тест.
Игорь А.: И, соответственно, мы его сейчас оцифровали, и хотим как раз -таки вот что попробовать и протестировать. Мы его оцифровали, мы действительно на некоторых наших новых клиентах, которые
Игорь А.: приходят, мы не по -старому, а по -новому действуем. Соответственно, они проходят это тестирование, и дальше у нас буквально после этого еще есть один созвон либо с профориентологом,
Игорь А.: либо с психологом. Мы там смотрим уже, насколько мячится в семье, голос ребенка слышен, в принципе, взаимопонимание и принятие того отчета, который наше тестирование показало. Так вот,
Игорь А.: вот этот продукт мы решили сейчас не в широкую массу вести, а запустить через наших экспертов -партнеров. То есть я говорю, что это не собеседование, а приглашение в вот эту часть продукта,
Игорь А.: в которой есть еще одна роль, которая называется партнер. И она, естественно, не безвозмездная. Я поэтому и спрашивал, какой чек там и так далее. Потому что, по сути, мы продаем вот
Игорь А.: эту услугу профориентации. Там самый минимум, то есть вот я сам там с дочками проходил эти профориентации, сам, скажем так, по своим знакомым и продал эти профориентации. По рекомендации
Игорь А.: такой самый низкий легкий чек – это 20 -35 тысяч, некоторые покупают там по 150 -250 тысяч. Все зависит от, условно говоря, это ультра -хай -нетворк, либо это массовый сегмент. Поэтому
Игорь А.: здесь верхней планки нет, но есть нижняя, не ниже 20 тысяч, с которой 7 тысяч получить. Ну и опять же, евро неважно, мы это все, есть и британский счет у нас, и все эти вопросы решаемые
Игорь А.: с переводами. То есть во что я приглашаю? Вот этот цифровой продукт, который является стартовой точкой.
Игорь А.: Если есть семьи, которым действительно, то есть это не про впаривание, это не про то, что типа вот сейчас нужно дать ответ и так далее. Это можно подумать, если вдруг у какой -то семьи
Игорь А.: есть такое желание, можно этот продукт им порекомендовать. За рекомендацию и за то, что мы там дальше все тестирование проводим, и человека начинаем подключать уже в систему. и, естественно,
Игорь А.: вас тоже как эксперта мы тоже подключим потом систему, то есть мы сейчас там свои, скажем так, связки тестируем и звонки, и все это оцифровываем, вы получаете как партнер 35 % с продажи.
Игорь А.: Поэтому мы там не ставим условно верхнюю планку, потому что знаем, что мы сами можем один и тот же продукт, ну, условно говоря, будем честны, можем продать и за 250, и за 500. То есть
Игорь А.: как бы у каждого свои навыки, и каждая семья считает свою нормой, а кому -то 20. Ну вот, как бы понятное дело, что дальше потом разные профориентологи могут подключаться. И как развитие
Игорь А.: всей этой истории, мы сделаем потом свое внутреннее обучение для экспертов, чтобы, например, цена, например, вы ставите там 2000 евро или там 3000 евро, например. спрашивает окей хорошо
Игорь А.: я видел такую же за тысячу да но здесь буду проводить я потом вам и я буду вам объяснять его я вам буду помогать там с вузом с направлением там и так далее мы будем вот это как раз
Игорь А.: обучение потом второе проводить именно для тех партнеров которые являются во первых экспертами но не просто там любой сможет сделать а вот тот который действительно эксперт в какой
Игорь А.: -то области Ну и, во -вторых, те, которые взаимодействуют с семьями продолжительное время, потому что достаточно просто, вот я даже предложил, хоп, ссылку сформировали, отправили. И
Игорь А.: вот этот кабинет у нас будет готов на этой неделе, мы его сейчас тестируем. И как раз -таки моя цель текущего звонка – рассказать об этой возможности и пригласить, потестировать, чтобы
Игорь А.: мы вот, если вдруг есть там какие -то семьи, которым это полезно, мы с ними оттестировали с вашей помощью. То есть вы там формируете сами цену, вы формируете полностью в кабинете все
Игорь А.: эти реферальные ссылки, все мы хвосты, все это видим, поэтому мы там скрупулезно свою эту платформу делаем. И дальше, соответственно, когда мы скажем по своим стандартам, что да, вот
Игорь А.: действительно продукт хороший, NPC хорошая, у нас отзывы классные, мы можем идти на широкую аудиторию, уже активно привлекать большое количество экспертов на платформу и большое количество
Игорь А.: людей в принципе в трафик вкладываться, дальше привлекать. Вот, так что вот суть звонка, вот суть продукта, поэтому, если в целом интересно, можете там поделиться обратной связью и
Игорь А.: позадавать свои вопросы.
Александра: Да, спасибо, интересная презентация, мне понравилось, что можно, ну, вообще, мне кажется, вот эта тема профориентации, она уже давно где -то есть, и я помню, что у нас тоже она была
Александра: еще лет там 10 назад, но не в таком, конечно, качественном формате, поэтому я понимаю, что там не за 40 страниц и не на атом, и там все разбиралось, это точно. По поводу
Александра: студентов и абитуриентов, ко мне, конечно, приходят чаще всего люди, которые решили пойти в дизайн уже. У меня бывает, но редко, когда приходит кто -то помладше, например, даже там
Александра: 12 -14 лет, и, допустим, когда ребенок знает, что он хочет в дизайн, но не знает в какой, в CGI или в fashion, или там еще куда -то. То есть вот тогда они приходят, что -то вроде вот
Александра: этой профориентации мы делаем, но они просто показывают, это как консультация в ревью -портфолио, ревью работ, которые были проделаны. Я просто смотрю от самых первых работ до последних
Александра: работ, чтобы видеть, какая там есть динамика и куда человек
Игорь А.: вообще ведет, неосознанно или осознанно. Вот, то есть что -то подобное иногда я делаю, но у меня просто меньше, наверное, запроса на такие штуки среди моих клиентов, потому что в основном
Игорь А.: там уже все те, кто как Марк, да, допустим, они метались -метались и определились в какой -то момент. Марк 3 профориентации прошел, прошу прощения, что перебиваю то есть это не это
Игорь А.: не разовая история то есть проходят поступаем тоже динамику наблюдаем например как оценки идут как там успеваемость потом через полгода год опять еще раз делаем профориентацию эту же
Игорь А.: то есть это такое тестирование которое она там как чекпоинт
Александра: в
Игорь А.: маршруте проходится несколько раз потому что иногда там вырос условно говоря человек из какого -то некого образа либо состояния и нужно его перенаправить потому что вроде бы направление
Игорь А.: тоже как вы правильно говорите а есть web design а есть fashion design то есть как бы как айти ты работаешь войти окей хорошо кем ты работаешь и можно список этих профессий перечислять
Игорь А.: там до вот поэтому да то есть это не одноразовая услуга мы когда берем клиента на сопровождение он проходит эти истории то есть это не разовая история это как точка входа и потом соответственно
Игорь А.: ведем его и рекомендуем еще раз то есть например ваш клиент еще раз проходит вам еще раз проходит еще раз и И тут, знаете, есть часть, которая вообще не знает, куда хочет, или, например,
Игорь А.: родители просто хотят, а часть, которая знает, вот у меня, например, по старшей дочке, у меня прям все совпало. То есть прям точно до специальности, которая ей была интересна. А там
Игорь А.: по младшей дочке, по средней дочке, в общем, у нее там, ну так пока, непонятно. Вот, поэтому, ну она помладше, там ей 12, ей еще так. то есть но по крайней мере ну а еще младшие дети
Игорь А.: и они еще пока им вообще рано вот поэтому тут момент в том что некоторым можно показать что да этот путь правильный тоже то есть это когда целеустремленные это тоже хорошо а
Александра: мне интересно про ориентацию проходит только ребенок или родитель там тоже идет с каким -то тестом родители тоже проходят да
Игорь А.: родители тоже проходит тест но это такой семейный слой то есть он для контекста семьи сколько например как видит родитель своего ребенка вообще слышит он его не слышит общается ли с
Игорь А.: ним сколько по мнению родителя ребенок уделяет время учебе ну то есть там вот такие вопросы вот как кем вообще родитель видит своего ребенка потому что ребенок вообще себя например
Игорь А.: может может тем же видеть кем -то то То есть, например, это обсуждаемая тема в семье, куда ребенок пойдет. А может вообще ребенок закрыться в какой -то момент, быть вот как Марк, например.
Игорь А.: Но не открываться долгое время, пока не найдется направление, в котором он действительно будет счастлив, когда выпустится и начнет работать. Поэтому разные истории бывают. Но родители
Игорь А.: тоже проходят тесты, иногда по результатам тестов у нас, например, подключается пакет с психологами прежде всего для родителей. И потом уже там для детей. Вот такая история.
Александра: Очень часто я вижу, когда родители очень сильно влияют на ребенка в таком возрасте, еще когда на него можно влиять. Я иногда, зная и родителя, и общаясь с ребенком на занятиях, я вижу
Александра: очень прямую корреляцию. мне кажется это один человек которого просто один нес просто какую -то мысль и долбил другому грубо говоря это очень иногда настолько бывает ребенок в этом
Александра: возрасте еще с родителям как
Александра: не отдельно думает вообще не отдельно думает совместно с родителем только в связке с родителями Поэтому мне интересно было уточнить. Хорошо, я поняла. Ну, тогда что от меня сейчас требуется?
Александра: Какие -то данные, что -то где -то зарегистрироваться?
Игорь А.: У нас кабинет запускается на этой неделе, как только все будет готово. То есть там сейчас справки вносим, редактируем. Но я думаю, что где -то четверг, пятница вот так вот будет хороший
Игорь А.: готовый кабинет. через Алину, либо там напрямую скину данную информацию, и можем еще раз там потом созвониться, я проведу по кабинету, по функциям, покажу это все. То есть можно будет
Игорь А.: подключиться, и вот в своем режиме можно активно, можно неактивно, то есть в любом случае, если нужно будет там самостоятельно пройти, посмотреть, это тоже там рассматривается, мы можем
Игорь А.: предоставить там доступ. Но в целом все будет там в кабинете партнера, все будет видно, и как раз таки, Вы как, когда подключитесь в кабинет партнера, вам автоматически там будет доступен
Игорь А.: кабинет как пользователя. И там, ну, вы увидите
Александра: все эти функции и эксперта, и пользователя. Ну, в общем -то, просто партнер – это как отдельный еще слой, который мы сейчас закладываем, и одно другому вообще не противоречит. Вот у
Александра: нас, например, мы тестировали на учениках своих, и девушка говорит, да я порекомендую, и мне деньги не нужны, вы мне лучше их в виде занятий, пожалуйста. Ну, то есть варианты вообще
Александра: разные. Поэтому я понимаю, что для эксперта лучше деньгами, поэтому мы такого важного смысла дали. Да, отлично, хорошо. Я остаюсь на связи, интересное предложение, давайте посмотрим,
Александра: куда это приведет.
Игорь А.: Да, Александра, хорошо. Спасибо большое. Мне кажется,
Александра: все равно это что -то новое, да. Да,
Игорь А.: рад был с вами повидаться. Я тогда, как только кабинет появится, вам информацию пришлю. Плюс, если нужно будет по самой профориентации, там тоже информацию поскидываю, чтобы... Ну,
Игорь А.: в общем, ближе к делу, я тогда вам с вами материалами поделюсь.
Александра: Да, спасибо, взаимно. До встречи.
Игорь А.: До встречи, благодарю. До свидания.